hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd hardware review video today i'll be
reviewing the wireless flexible
multimedia keyboard sent to me by the
people at ds international and uh if you
want to check out the unboxing video you
can obviously click that annotation
right there and that is basically it so
let's just head right on to this review
the ds international flexible keyboard
is a sort of an odd yet an interesting
gadget uh just like the name says
obviously it's flexible keyboard you can
completely fold it up and uh since it's
most likely going to be carried around
with you it is dust proof and it is
completely moisture proof so you don't
have to keep it in your backpack if
you're actually going to carry it around
you can just carry it
as you can see here this this keyboard
actually has all the same features and
keys as a regular standard keyboard uh
and also the way that it's shaped and
what it's made of is very solidly made
and it allows you to type extremely
quietly and it does take a good couple
of days to get used to typing on this
keyboard full time
but allows you to type away quite
quietly and not disturbing anyone else
in your area so as you saw in the
unboxing video there's actually a few
things that come in the box number one
the mini cd you just saw and number two
the mini usb adapter so like you also
may have seen in the unboxing video
there are a number of fn keys at the top
including some browser forward backward
and refresh buttons and some media
control these are pretty good if you
have uh some kind of a netbook that
you're traveling with where you actually
don't have all the the keys that you
need and you need to carry along a
keyboard just like this where you can
have all the functionality of a
full-size keyboard two other things you
might want to know about the keyboard
are that one it runs on a aaa battery
system found in the left hand side of
the keyboard where you also press to
connect and number two is that it's 2.4
gigahertz wireless just two simple
things very very standard and the uh the
aaa batteries have lasted me uh this
long so pretty good connecting to your
computer is actually the easiest part
all you have to do is just take that usb
stick plug it into your computer and
push to connect and there's also a push
to connect on the keyboard and you'll
see it to start to blink once the
connection has occurred everything is
automatic the drivers the wireless
everything it works perfectly and i
really love how easy it is to connect so
that's that's definitely a pro for this
keyboard
now the only real quirks that i found
with this keyboard are that number one
there are there are two windows keys as
you can see here uh but that i really
got used to and the other thing is that
as you can see just to the left of the
spacebar there's a blank key that you
can still press but nothing happens when
you press it so those are the only two
slightly odd things but i mean you
really get used to them and you can type
just as well with those being there
now overall for those of you wondering
yes this is a full size keyboard as you
can see by the overlay here with my 17
inch laptop
completely full size 100 for those of
you who have a problem with small keys
so overall guys i'm going to have to
give this an 8 out of 10 and it's a very
solid keyboard for the price i might add
and you can check this all out at the
link in the description for the dsm
international website and uh so yeah
just go ahead and check that link in the
description and thank you very much for
watching this overall review video now
um this was definitely a new style of
review i filmed and edited this entire
thing with camtasia studio 6 so if you
have any other questions about how to do
that just go ahead and feel free to
message me
i guess using the annotation i'll pop up
there
and uh that is basically it so thank you
for watching this review video guys
again check it out if you decide to get
one just let me know down in the
comments and be sure to rate five stars
thanks for watching guys
you